this isn't normal
Marcus Rodriguez says over and over
there's garbage everywhere he looks
rotting here in Galicia garbage is toxic
to the environment for Marquez this is
home he's furious that people treat it
so badly there's a partridge it wants
water is beastly I grew up in nature it
hurts me to see all this filth why don't
people Karen Marcus's story is well
known in Spain at the age of seven he
found himself alone in a remote valley
in Sierra Morena he befriended wolf-cubs
and spent years living among them in
Spain's wilderness
[Music]
with eunuch whereby my gather medical
catch our oh my went into the cubs den
and fell asleep
[Music]
I think they weren't sure whether to
adopt me but I guess they left me
because I was playing with the Cubs
smelled like them washed myself in mud
dried myself with leaves I think it was
the smell that made me one of them
Marcus a story was made into a movie
his stepmother used to beat him his
father couldn't look after him he was
abandoned and left with a shepherd who
soon died Markos stayed in the wild and
hunted with Wolves he didn't have
contact with humans until police found
him when he was 19 and forced him to
leave the woods
Marko's is 72 today he had to work hard
to learn to speak again but he's never
been able to come to terms with
civilizations darker side he has few
friends one of whom is cozy
a forest ranger who shares Marcoses
passion for nature and his fear of its
destruction there was a forest fire here
the risk of more of them in Ganesha is
high our work has been in vain
powerless angry I don't know what to say
most of these fires were started by
humans by arsonists police have arrested
several suspects but still there was no
end to the forest fires Marcos is
appalled almost nothing survives here
anymore burn it all down there'll be
nothing left if they keep this up half
the human population will die if nature
is understand how humans can let this
happen
but Marcos is a fighter despite his
bitter experiences he hopes people can
learn to care for the natural
environment for years he's been visiting
schools to speak with children he makes
a convincing case with his authenticity
a wonderful nature advocate he knows
animals better than he knows people you
can learn so much from him like how to
be respectful of the natural environment
when Marcos explains this to you it is
completely different than when
scientists do it but as time passes
Marcos has begun doubting whether he can
make a lasting impression on people
yellow Daniel see I talked to children
about nature a lot and tell them it's
the most wonderful thing there is they
must treat nature with care but I don't
know if they really hear me it's hard to
change humans and we matter the other
cumbia anthem man-wolf taught Marcos to
respect nature people showed him how
they destroy it
which leaves Marcos to wonder whether a
part of him will always be more wolf
than human
[Laughter]
[Music]